Although most developers
don't focus on it,
font is often the most
critical component
of your application or website.
If you don't have the right
font for the right language,
all your build for design
can quickly be destroyed.
Hi, my name is Xiangye
Xiao, and today I
will talk about Google's
international font Noto.
Let's look at a few examples.
On the left image,
characters for Meetei Mayek
are displayed as Tofu.
Effectively, the characters
are displayed as little boxes
to indicate your device
doesn't have a font
to display the text.
The image on the
right highlights
another difficult situation.
The text is there,
but ugly because it's
displayed using fonts of
mismatched styles and weights.
Developers constantly have
to address both issues.
But sadly, solutions
aren't always ideal.
For example, the Daily Express
Urdu, a Pakistani news website,
runs into the problem that
the Urdu Nastaleeq font
style, preferred by
Pakistani people,
isn't available for the
majority of devices.
So they had to
pre-process every web page
to present images instead.
While that works, it pulls
a tremendous amount of time
in preprocessing as well as
bandwidth for the servers
and load time for the users,
which isn't really ideal.
With the goal of
supporting all languages
with a harmonious
look and feel, Google
has been developing a
font family called Noto.
Noto is Google's answer to Tofu.
The name Noto is to convey
the idea that Google's goal is
to see no more Tofu.
To date, Noto has supported
over 300 languages,
using more than 90 scripts,
covering 110,000 characters.
It has covered all
major living languages,
such as English, Vietnamese,
Greek, Russian, Thai, Arabic,
Hebrew, Chinese, Japanese,
Korean, Hindi, Urdu,
and way beyond.
It also supports
smaller languages,
like Meetei Mayek and
even ancient languages,
like Egyptian hieroglyphics.
Look at this image.
It includes a sample of Noto
for a subset of languages
supported by this font.
I bet only a small
number of people
could find Cherokee and
cuneiform in the image.
As a developer, supporting
different languages
comes with a bit of overhead
that you have to design for.
In addition to eliminating Tofu,
another important goal of Noto
is to provide harmonious look
and feel across languages.
To achieve harmony is
not as simple as setting
the same height
for all languages.
For example, tall languages,
like Tibetan in this image,
will look really
squeezed and much harder
to read than English, although
the same height for English
and Tibetan is actually set.
Different baselines and vertical
metrics of different languages
need to be considered
to achieve harmony.
But with Noto this
isn't a problem.
On the right image, you can
see how two popular English
and Thai fonts make the text
difficult to read and messy.
Look at the different
sizes, spacing,
and the letter kerning.
But with Noto on the
left, these values
are nicely normalized,
so each language is just
as easy to read as the next.
But don't worry.
All of this support doesn't
come at the cost of the design
choices that so many beautiful
applications require.
Noto provides
sans-serif and the serif
styles for many languages.
It supports seven
weights for CJK
and two weights for
many other languages.
In some cases, Noto
represents the frontier
of font development.
For example, Noto Sans CJK is
the very first pan-CJK font
family in the world.
It supports
ideographic characters
following different
regional writing conventions
for simplified Chinese,
traditional Chinese, Japanese,
and the Korean users.
So in the past, quite of
few Taiwanese Android users
were upset because a lot of
traditional Chinese characters
were displayed in a wrong way.
Look at the highlighted
text in the screenshot.
Three out of eight
characters are
wrong with the old
font on Android.
Now with Noto, Taiwanese
users can finally
see their language displayed
in the right way on Android
since Lollipop.
What's best, Noto is open source
and free for anybody to use,
such as bundled with your
app or used as a web font.
Noto has been used by
Android and Chrome OS
as the default system fonts.
Many Noto fonts are also onboard
on Google Web Fonts Early
Access and was broadly picked
up by popular Linux distros.
To date, 1 billion users are
benefitting from Noto fonts
on their phones, tablets,
desktops, and even wearables.
As developers start looking
towards international success,
getting the font right
is the first big problem
you have to tackle, and with
Noto it's not a problem at all.
So download the Noto
packages and start
thinking globally today.
Thank you.